翻訳: Kouki Okawara
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私 置き忘れがとてもひどいんです
例えばこれ
普段使っている鍵の束なんですが
決して小さいものではありません
これを 家でも 会社でも 出先でも
１日に５回はどこかに置き忘れて
「俺の鍵見なかった？」と
毎日 色々な人に聞き回っています
ちなみ この会場についてから
すでに２回 鍵をなくしています
（笑）
１回鍵を探すのに 10分はかかりますから
１日５回で 50分
それが 家でも会社でも 365日ですから
年間約300時間
実に１年のうち 12日間以上
私は 鍵を探し続けている計算になります
おかげで 鍵以外のものを
なかなか探す時間が取れず
未だに 33歳独身です
（笑）
私は苦手なものが もう１つあります
私 人の機嫌を損ねるのが
とても得意なんです
これも特に女性
（笑）
先日 久しぶりに会った同世代の女性に
こう言いました
「なんか しばらく見ないうちに
すごい 化粧がうまくなったね」
（笑）
不思議なことに 彼女は無言で無表情でした
褒めたはずなのに
でも 空気の読めない私でも
さすがに気付きました
これはもしかしたら お世辞だと思って
がっかりしているんじゃないか
もっと心込めて言わなきゃ
（笑）
「お世辞なんかじゃないよ
本当に前 会ったときとは
別人のように
（笑）
化粧がうまくなった
まるで化粧だけじゃないみたいだ」
ちなみに 悪気は全くありません
その私の
毎日のように 鍵を置き忘れ続けるであるとか
毎日のように女性を怒らせてばかりであるとか
これは 私が働く福祉の世界では
「とても苦手」とは
まだ別の言い方があります
極度の置き忘れの多さは
「注意欠陥障害」 通称「ADD」
人の気持ちが推測できず
怒らせてばかりなのは
「自閉症スペクトラム」 通称「ASD」
この２つをざっくりまとめて
「発達障害」と言ったりします
ここで 皆さんにちょっと
確かめて欲しいことがあります
今 私は 自分自身の
とても苦手なことについて
話をしているのでしょうか？
それとも 自分自身の発達障害について
告白をしているところなのでしょうか？
今 皆さんは どちらに
感じられていますか？
私の話の
「障害」と 「とても苦手」の
境目ってどこにあるんでしょう？
ここで２つ 質問があります
必ず心の中で 手をあげてください
１つ目
私は障害を持っているという方
心の中で手をあげてください
ありがとうございます
もう１つ
私にはとても苦手なことがあるという方
心の中で手をあげてください
ありがとうございます
心の手が見えました
そのとき 「障害を持っている」と
いうことに手をあげた方は
おそらく少数です
でも 「とても苦手なことがある」
に手をあげたのは
この会場の ほとんど
全ての方ではないでしょうか？
このときの 皆さんが
手をあげた明確な差ほど
障害と 苦手の 境目って
明らかなんでしょうか？
このとき みなさんが
手をあげたときに 分けたのは
障害がある側と そうではない側の
自分かもしれません
障害者とそうではない側の自分を
分ける境目って
皆さん どこにあるんでしょうか？
考えたことはありますか？
福祉では
「 IQが70以下であれば 知的障害」
という定義があります
しかし ここで皆さんに
考えていただきたいのは
定義の話ではなく
あなた自身が どこをどう判断して
誰かを障害者だと感じ
自分を 障害者ではないと
捉えているのでしょう？
定義通り IQ70以下の方を見たら
知的障害だと 皆さんは感じるでしょうか？
それでしたら IQ180を超える
アインシュタインから見て
私たちは知的なハンディを
抱えているように見えないでしょうか？
同じように 100mを9秒58で走る
ウサイン・ボルトから見て
そこから５秒以上遅れてゴールする私たちは
身体的なハンディを抱えているように
見えないでしょうか？
あるいは私は
１年のうち 何時間以上
鍵を置き忘れ続ければ
それは障害になるんでしょう？
私は １年のうち女性を怒らせるのを
何回に以下に抑えれば
それを 「発達障害」ではなく
「とても苦手」と言っていいんでしょう？
私は 障害者なんでしょうか？
皆さん どう感じていますか？
私の答えは「ノー」です
私は 障害者ではありません
私は 毎日のように 鍵を置き忘れ続け
毎日ように 女性の機嫌を
損ねてばかりいるだけの
１人の人間です
私は 障害者っていう人は
この世界の どこにもいないと思っています
今この瞬間も障害者と呼ばれている人たちは
あなたたちと あなたと同じく
何かとても苦手なことを持つ １人１人です
障害者っていう人は
この世界のどこにも存在しない
では 障害って一体 どこにあるんでしょう？
考えたことはありますか？
「バリアフリー」という言葉があります
その「バリア」は
その辺りの通りの道路に
段差として存在しているわけでもなければ
障害者と呼ばれている人たちが
抱えているものでもありません
本来は とてもとても曖昧な
「障害」と 「とても苦手」
その間に 無意識に
明確な線を引こうとする試み
例えば 支援をされる側と 支援をする側
無条件に手を差し伸べるべき側と
原則自己責任の側
かわいそうな側と 恵まれた側
時には 無条件に純粋無垢であり
善人である側と そうではない側
その間に １人１人が
無意識に引こうとしている その線こそが
私は唯一 「障害」と呼べるもの
だと思っています
私は 長年の車椅子の友人と
こんなやりとりをします
「おい 変態車椅子おじさん」
これは 彼と一緒に買い物に行ったとき
会計をしている横で
後ろからレジの女の子に向かって
「お姉さん かわいいですね」と
急に声をかけるからです
（笑）
一緒に買い物をしている横で
急にナンパをし出す友人に
「変態」と言うことに
皆さん 異論はないですよね？
一方で私が —
よく顔を見てください —
「おーい ゴリラ ウホッとか言ってみろ」
と言われることもあります
これ どちらも身体的な特徴を
揶揄したやりとりなんです
もしかしたら そのやりとりを見て
私が彼を 「変態車椅子おじさん」
と呼んでいるのを見て
何か 周りの人は感じているかもしれません
でも 私と彼との間には
遮るものは何もありません
これだけは 確かです
そんな彼らが
私に教えてくれたことがあります
自分の障害
自分のハンディキャップ
自分のとても苦手なこと
言い方なんて 何でもいいんです
私が ここにいる私たち全てが
何かとても苦手なこと
ハンディキャップを持つ１人１人です
そしてその誰もが
自分のとても苦手なことについて
他の誰かのサポートを受けています
そうですよね？
たとえ直接 手を差し伸べられていなくても
自分のとても苦手なことについて
「仕方ないなー」と受け入れてくれ
フォローしてくれている方が
皆さんの周りに必ずいるはずです
私たちは全て
自分のとても苦手なところを抱え
それを他の誰かにサポートされ
なんとか生きています
なんとか
それを 障害者と呼ぶのであれば
私たちは皆んな 障害者です
どうか 確かめてみてください
そこには引くべき一線も
取り除くべき障害も
ならすべき段差も 壊すべき壁も
最初から なかったんです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）